late last night the daily warrior broke
what is
certainly the wildest most insane and
sickest story of the year the reporter
the indomitable luke rosiak excellent
reporter for daily wire he's the one who
broke the story so we've been hearing
for weeks now about the supposed
domestic terrorist movements in the
united states no we're not talking about
the kkk no we're not talking about black
lives matter rioters we are talking of
course
about parents who are going to school
board meetings and then saying things
which is super duper scary and there are
certain people who've been made the face
of this supposed domestic terror
movement people who have been treated as
though they are a deep abiding violent
threat to teachers and school boards
across the nation well this is the story
according to daily wire of one of those
people his name is scott smith here's
luke rosiak writing and this is a
disturbing story and you'll see why it's
so disturbing and what it really has to
do with is the fact that the elitists in
our society have cut themselves off from
the rest of america and now are
attempting to dictate policy to everyone
else at the cost of human decency
on june 22 scott smith was arrested at
loudoun county virginia school board
meeting a meeting that was ultimately
deemed an unlawful assembly after many
attendees vocally opposed a policy on
transgender students what people did not
know is that weeks prior on may 28th
says smith a boy allegedly wearing a
skirt entered a girl's bathroom at
nearby stone bridge high school where he
sexually assaulted smith's ninth grade
daughter
juvenile records are sealed but smith's
attorney elizabeth lancaster told the
daily wire that a boy was charged with
two counts of forcible sodomy one count
of anal sodomy one count of forcible
fellatio related to an incident that day
at the school
as a result of the viral video showing
his arrest smith became the poster child
for what the national school boards
association has since suggested could be
a form of domestic terrorism a white
blue-collar male who showed up to
harangue obscure public servants on his
local school board
lancaster lawyer said if somebody would
have sat and listened for 30 seconds to
what scott had to say they would have
been mortified and heartbroken
minutes before smith's arrest the
loudoun county public schools
superintendent lectured the public that
concerns about the transgender policy
were misplaced because the school system
had no record of any assault occurring
in any school bathroom
then a woman wearing a rainbow heart
shirt a left-wing community activist
told smith she did not believe his
daughter he says his rage reached a boil
and he had a heated exchange of words
with a woman a police officer there to
keep the peace in the meeting pulled on
his arm smith yanked it away before he
knew it smith says he was hit in the
face handcuffed and dragged across the
floor with his pants pulled down images
of the incident were splashed on tvs and
newspapers across the world
but
the county's progressive and top elected
prosecutor who has close ties to the
school board's most liberal members
appeared in court to personally
prosecute smith for disorderly conduct
and resisting arrest mibaraj ran on a
platform of ending mass incarceration
but she wanted to put smith in jail for
the misdemeanors
as prosecutor mibaraj would have known
about the case involving smith's
daughter the suspect juvenile court
prosecutors assured smith was being held
responsible he was on house arrest
confined to his mother's townhouse
according to lancaster a conviction was
expected on october 14th likely in the
form of a guilty plea to a lesser sexual
assault charge but on october 6th
according to the loudoun county
sheriff's office a 15 year old was
charged with sexual battery and
abduction after police said he forced a
girl into an empty classroom held her
against her will and touched her
inappropriately
lancaster says the suspect is the same
boy who allegedly attacked smith's
daughter
what follows based on extensive
exclusive reporting from loudoun county
is smith's experience it is a story the
school system and media were never going
to tell
so the short story here and we'll get to
the details in a second is that one of
the parents who was protesting a school
board and was speaking about the threat
of transgender bathroom policy had a
daughter who was allegedly raped in the
bathroom by a boy wearing a skirt
and when he started to say what he
thought people started to get angry at
him and this resulted in him being
branded a quote-unquote domestic
terrorist by the media and the face of
this very upset movement
again the father of the girl
here's the story on may 28th stonebridge
high school called smith to come to the
school
they told him his 15 year old daughter
had just been physically assaulted in a
bathroom by a male
when he arrived he determined that what
had happened was not a case of his
daughter being beaten up it was far more
serious the school said it was handling
the incident in-house smith was
dumbfounded
deputies from the sheriff's office
ultimately responded to the school not
to investigate the alleged rape of a
child smith said but because school
administrators called them on him for
making a scene about it
smith acknowledges he didn't make a
scene he says any father would have done
the same he said i went nuts i called
the principal a p word six cop cars
showed up like an effing swat team to
respond to the school's complaints about
an assertive parents he said thank god i
drew enough attention to it without
getting arrested that we got an escort
to the hospital and they administered a
rape kit that night
a sane exam in buckle swab his lawyer
said came back later favorable to the
prosecution's case
all juvie records are sealed the
sheriff's office declined to release
records relating to smith to the daily
wire but in response to a public request
record public records request confirmed
that a report with offense forcible
sodomy and sexual battery matching that
date and location exists
at 448 on the day of the incident the
principal sent out an email to the
community that claimed nothing
jeopardizing student safety had occurred
painting smith is the villain and
offering counseling services for
witnesses of smith's up the letter said
quote
good evening stonebridge families this
is stonebridge principal tim flynn there
was an incident in the main office area
today that required the loudoun county
sheriff's office to dispatch deputies to
stonebridge the incident was confined to
the main office and the entrance area to
the school there was no threat to the
safety of the student body the incident
was witnessed by a small number of
students we're meeting with the staff
adjacent to the main office counseling
services and the services of our unified
mental health team are available for any
student who may need to talk about
today's incident
lcps washed their hands at the smith
said it was only taken seriously because
of the sheriff's office
the lcps director of communications said
only that quote any information related
to student information is confidential
under state and federal laws regarding
student
privacy lancaster this is the lawyer
told the daily wire she accompanied
smith's starters meetings with
prosecutors that the suspect made
self-incriminating statements in an
interview that prosecutors brought the
charges and that a conviction was
expected imminently likely in the form
of a plea deal to a charge of felony
aggravated sexual battery smith had not
opposed the downgrade saying about the
boy what if he made one mistake
on june 22 school board held a meeting
where the focus of discussion was a
proposal expanding special protections
to transgender students
smith showed up out of practical
concerns
my wife and i are gay and lesbian
friendly smith said we're not into this
children transgender stuff the person
that attacked our daughter is apparently
bisexual and occasionally wears dresses
because he likes them so this kid is
technically not what the school board
was fighting about the point is kids are
using it as an advantage to get into the
bathrooms
from the dais school board member beth
bars painted such concerns as paranoia
and prejudice
our students do not need to be protected
and they are not in danger she said do
we have assaults in our bathrooms or
locker rooms regularly
superintendent scott ziegler replied
quote to my knowledge we don't have any
record of assaults occurring in our
restrooms
board chair brenda sheridan asked have
we had any issues involving transgender
students in our bathrooms or locker
rooms
zigler answered
time magazine in 2016 called that a red
herring that the data was simply not
playing out that transgender students
were more likely to assault cisgender
students in restrooms than other
students
smith tried to contain himself as the
activists who prioritized had lived
experience and believed women ignored
his daughter
nearly 250 members of the public had
signed up to speak
many of them were critical of the school
system's racial and transgender
initiatives others were supporters of
the transgender policy who painted their
neighbors as ignorant bigots with one
saying hate was dripping from the
followers of jesus in this room
opponents booed at the remark the board
threatened to stop the meeting if
participants were loud again
after another speaker blasted the school
board for suspending a teacher named
tanner cross for speaking in opposition
to a transgender proposal the crowd
cheered and the board shut the meeting
down
two courts later ruled cross had to be
reinstated
apparently
after far left board member barts was
elected in 2019 with 55 percent of the
vote she lashed out at parents who
disagreed with progressives and teachers
union-backed policies so often and with
such vitriol that most of her peers who
agreed with reviews censured her and
strips her of her committee assignments
bart's then retreated to a facebook
group officially known as the
anti-racist parents of loudoun county
later known to critics as chardonnay
antifa
and she started targeting people in the
parent community
who were questioning the loudoun county
school board
okay but this apparently came to a it's
sort of logical apex at this june 22nd
meeting
apparently
one of the parents confronted smith
okay because smith was talking about
what had happened to his daughter
a parent named jackie schwarm confronted
him schwarm was at the june 22 school
board meeting wearing a shirt with a
rainbow heart on it as a girl scout
troop leader
jazz had mentioned swarm's daughter
smith and jess just as the wife
said swarm sought them out in the crowds
demanding to know which side they were
on then berated them they were in the
wrong
jazz who was this smith asked his wife i
thought she was my friend jess said
smith tried to tell her what had
happened to his daughter he said and she
looks me dead in the eyes and says
that's not what happened
shawn then noticed that smith was
wearing a shirt with the name of his
plumbing business on it and she goes oh
i'm going to ruin your business on
social media
you're a b-word smith told her video
shows a police officer monitoring the
tension-filled exchange pulled on
smith's arm he yanked it away and soon
smith and the officer were wrestling
just cried out in words lost in the
chaos my child was raped at school and
this is what happens smith was charged
with disorderly conduct and resisting
arrest
swarm this this rival parent actually
did a 40-minute phone call with the
daily wire and contended she had no
relationship with the topic
that she didn't have any sort of
argument with smith and didn't know he
had been arrested
after the daily wire offered evidence of
her involvement she said she went over
to ask just for a play date between
their teenage daughters
she claimed she asked jaz how she was
doing switch just purportedly responded
we know critical race theory isn't real
but we don't want them to know it
schwarm told the daily wire that if
smith's daughter told them she was raped
by a martian she would believe her but
she also made repeated comments about
the daughter's mental stability
as to her comments on the facebook group
she told the daily wire the group was
apolitical that she had never taken part
in list making activities
and then she started calling other
parents racists
after swarm repeatedly brought up that
smith was convicted of a crime the daily
wire asked if a restorative justice
circle a technique pushed by progressive
prosecutors as an alternative to
punishment would have been a positive
resolution to the arrest
apparently schwarm then said she did not
know what restorative justice was and
wasn't interested
okay this entire thing ended up on
national tv
and the entire story ended up being a
story about how smith was a terrible
person who is trying to terrify members
of the school board
and the prosecutor decided to go forward
with the case and try to prosecute smith
and throw him in jail for all of this
smith said nothing as his likeness
travels around the world the avatar of
ignorant bigotry advisers told him it'd
be better to let the process against his
daughter's assailant play out he didn't
want to risk interfering
the culprit was expected to plead guilty
on october 14th but then there was a
second case
in which apparently the same teenager
was charged with forcing a victim into
an empty classroom where he held her
against her will and inappropriately
touched her
the daily wire is withholding the name
of the suspect because of his age
reached it home his mother declined to
comment on the allegations
so here is the bottom line two girls
allegedly sexually assaulted in school
four months apart by the same person so
far the only person to be convicted of a
crime is the victim's father a school
policy passed following what appeared to
be false statements from the
superintendent the superintendent said
that nothing bad had happened at school
that is not true
the prosecutor bibaraj has not returned
a request for comment
though the injection of politics into
schools and criminal justice have led to
pain where there was none before and
enemies where they were once neighbors
it is possible some elected officials of
loudoun county might actually believe
this story has a happy ending though
smith's daughter has been allegedly
raped and separately beaten at school
the teen has adopted increasingly strong
progressive views over the course of her
tenure at lcps where did she get these
ideas from school obviously said yes
it's not from our home
okay that's the craziest story of the
day but unfortunately this is part and
parcel of the the issues that we are
told don't matter we are told that
parents are not supposed to worry about
this that educators are going to be
handling the education of your children
that the school boards ought to be is
what terry mcauliffe says in virginia
and that if you have any serious
questions about this if in fact your
child has suffered at the hands of this
ideology
then you're making it all up it's all
fake that is what we are being told
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang